this video was made possible by
brilliant more on them later
in 2020 it was estimated that at least
one tonne in six of global carbon
emissions came from transport road
vehicles ships planes and trains in
order to prevent significant disruption
to our planet we must bring Global
carbon emissions down to zero which
means we need to decarbonize the
transport sector which means buy an
electric car and don't fly right
well yes and also no this is a very
complicated problem with a very
complicated solution that will vary
depending on where you live and how
wealthy you are this video isn't going
to be a detailed package of solutions
but instead an overview of how the
international transport Forum or ITF
respected multinational research group
has proposed and modeled how the world
can cut its transport emissions by the
year 2050. there are two kinds of
Transport moving people and moving
Freight these produced approximately
equal carbon emissions however as well
as considering the two different types
of transport it's also helpful to
consider three different distance scales
traveled Urban moving around within a
city into City moving between cities or
within rural areas and international
moving between countries and moving
between continents let's go through how
to decarbonize those three scales
starting with Urban transport right now
two out of every three Journeys made
around the world are made within cities
and because these are short Journeys
they contribute about a third of all
passenger emissions depending on how far
you're traveling within a city you might
walk or cycle take public transport
drive your own vehicle or ride share
what you choose to do will depend on any
number of factors and will vary wildly
by City therefore there is no
one-size-fits-all approach to
decarbonizing city-wide transport each
City will be different but here's what
will be Universal this Century more and
more people will live in cities and so
as cities grow it is important to keep
Services nearby and keep Journeys as
short as possible in other words we want
to avoid urban sprawl low density
neighborhoods that you have to travel
out of to do well anything the first
step city planners should keep cities
dense as they grow allowing more
Journeys to be taken on foot or by bike
or electric bike and should build
infrastructure to allow this however
you're still going to want to travel
across the city sometimes and while
cycle Lanes will make journeys of a few
kilometers more attractive they're not
always going to be practical and so we
come to the Second Step invest in public
transport in many places public
transport meaning buses trams Metro
Light Rail is seen as a service taken
when there is no alternative making
buses and trams an attractive high
quality service will encourage their use
and combined with electrification have
many benefits including reduced
congestion better air quality and of
course lower carbon emissions all of
this accomplished because it will make
people less likely to drive their own
vehicle cars are realistically going to
be part of urban life this Century
though they produce fully one-third of
All Transport emissions so step three we
must indeed replace internal combustion
engine cars with zero emission Vehicles
such as electric cars this can be
accomplished in many ways initially
incentivizing electric car uptake making
them more affordable by for example
making them exempt from Road tax and
then later disincentivize the use of
internal combustion engine Vehicles such
as through zero emission zones in City
centers this does come with a few
problems it's estimated that most
countries have less than half the power
output required to support electric
vehicle fleets in 2030. New Power
Generation is needed and of course step
4 New Power Generation needs to be low
carbon no point electrifying everything
if your electricity Supply comes from
fossil fuels but what about Freight
transport within cities while you may
not think of it cities are nodes in the
Global Freight Network they are where
the majority of goods end up and as
middle classes grow so too will the
transport of freight to and within
cities this Century for example Urban
Freight demand is expected to Triple in
East and Northeast Asia by 2050. while
the electrification of light Goods
vehicles like Vans will be important as
will efficiency savings and systems
design companies sharing delivery
vehicles for example it's expected that
significant emission savings can come
from step 5 the use of cargo bikes and
particularly electric cargo bikes for
Last Mile deliveries a trend that's
already emerging and will likely become
more common City geography depending As
Cities become more dense how much carbon
do you emit by moving a person each
kilometer by car or train or plane well
we have data on that specifically in the
UK we can see that a petrol car has
about four times the carbon footprint
per kilometer as an electric car
emphasizing the importance of
transitioning to electric vehicles again
and about five times the footprint of a
train the only thing with a greater
footprint per kilometer is taking a
flight
this all becomes relevant when talking
about inter-city travel
how you decarbonize this kind of travel
will depend on how far you're traveling
and the geography of where you live if
traveling less than 500 kilometers
especially in Europe or South Asia you
are likely to take the train or drive
while if traveling that distance in
North America you are more likely to fly
or drive with trains unlikely to be an
option just as in cities cars will
remain a fixture of Transport at this
scale particularly when traveling in
rural areas so transitioning to zero
emission Vehicles is even more important
and will require step six government
investment in charging infrastructure
within communities and on key routes
both for passenger transport and for
Freight the ITF writes that
decarbonizing road Freight has received
less attention than passenger transport
modes but the ingredients are now in
place for a quiet revolution in low
carbon Logistics especially in developed
markets like Europe electric trucks and
other heavy Goods vehicles are likely to
be as cheap as their petrol and Diesel
counterparts in the 2030s to encourage
electrification then which will likely
start with lighter vehicles and then
scale up to heavy trucks step 7 policies
to encourage and facilitate electric
Freight such as tax exemptions should be
put in place
but this leaves the elephant in the room
cars and buses and trucks can be made
electric trains are already low carbon
and where electrified will only become
lower carbon
what about planes as the most carbon
intense way to travel there are many
people who think flights over short
distances should be banned a ban on
flights less than 500 kilometers in
length could move nearly 50 percent of
all short haul passengers to rail
transport by 2050. however this only
works if there is a rail alternative so
step 8 investment in rail infrastructure
especially High-Speed Rail if connecting
High population cities and especially in
Europe Australia North America and East
Asia is vital if you want an example of
what's possible here look at China's
incredible high-speed rail network
making domestic flights largely
unnecessary but this simply isn't going
to be practical everywhere either in
places like the Caribbean Indonesia or
the Philippines trains aren't going to
cut it much of the time and fairies
aren't always practical either flying is
here to stay especially when you look at
intern National travel now I'm going to
preface this by saying that yes there
are many places where international
travel is Easy by train Europe
especially but look at the modes of
Transport used when traveling over 3 000
kilometers a distance typically traveled
between countries it's dominated by
aircraft the ITF modeled how this
distribution of Passenger kilometers
might change by 2050 this is what it
looks like with current transport
policies and this is what it looks like
with really ambitious policies there
simply isn't an alternative to Flying
when transporting passengers very long
distances so what do we do about
Aviation how do we bring its emissions a
little over 10 percent of Total
Transport emissions down
well the first solution is Step nine
make some long distance trips
unnecessary as the pandemic demonstrated
much of what we would previously take a
plane to accomplish can now be done by
video call between teleworking and
raising awareness of the environmental
impact of flying we can reduce the total
number of Passenger kilometers traveled
by air by the current population of
course as the global middle class
increases in size this Century so too
will the demand for flying as such both
the ITF and the aviation industry see
two ways they can slash the emissions of
flying firstly step 10 improve the fuel
efficiency of planes by some admittedly
optimistic accounts by the ITF
improvements including changes to Wing
design reductions in taxi time and more
efficient engine design could see fuel
use per kilometer flown decrease by 57
though I'll believe that when I see it
secondly though Step 11 use alternative
fuels currently planes overwhelmingly
burn kerosene in their engines the
aviation industry expects most of their
emission cuts to come from sustainable
Aviation fuels or safs these are fuels
that instead of being made of oil pump
from the ground are produced from
biomass or synthetically through
hydrogen and captured carbon if such
fuels could be made they could be used
in existing infrastructure and existing
planes making their adoption very easy
however to say that these fuels are in
the early stages of development would be
generous whether bio or Electro fuels
could be made at scale and made with a
sufficiently low carbon footprint either
through land use or electricity is
simply unknown electric planes may be
applicable to some very short distance
routes but based on current technology
no more than that hydrogen could be used
as a fuel source but this is also in the
early stages of development and would
require additional infrastructure even
in the itf's ambitious policy framework
hydrogen isn't a factor until the late
2040s
Aviation then remains stubbornly
difficult to decarbonize safs are
unsurprisingly the industry's hope and
while underdeveloped could be considered
the most realistic of an unrealistic
bunch of solutions
flying is here to stay but for the time
being the best we can do is not do it
where possible
International Freight is a similar story
it's dominated not by planes but by
ships if you're moving something other
than a passenger between continents you
almost always do it by sea and by 2050
we currently expect a 95 increase in
international Freight similar to
Aviation this simply isn't going to
change anytime soon there is no
practical alternative to shipping so
instead of Reinventing the wheel step 12
improve the fuel efficiency of ships
through retrofitting existing vessels
and improving the designs of new ships
Complicated by the fact that ships tend
to be in service for over 25 years again
optimistic estimates suggest efficiency
improvements of 55 are possible through
installing DuckTales reducing
operational speed and improved
maintenance schedules additionally this
may sound familiar Step 13 use
alternative shipping fuels this could
partly mean wind power but realistically
it means similar fuels to those proposed
in aviation with all the Associated
problems but there is one final strategy
that is applicable to both Aviation and
shipping and the ITF recommends for
decarbonization at every distance scale
and that is step 14. carbon pricing this
is the idea that if you buy a product or
user service that causes the emission of
carbon you pay an extra charge
proportional to the amount of carbon
emitted the theory goes that consumers
will prefer to use services with lower
carbon Footprints to lower how much they
pay and so businesses are economically
encouraged to reduce their emissions in
a transport context it would for example
incentivize Airlines to switch to less
emitting fuels to remain cost
competitive with Alternatives like rail
it would also accelerate the uptake of
electric road vehicles exactly how this
carbon pricing would be enacted by whom
and what price should be set per tonne
of carbon is Up For Debate as is how to
avoid it unfairly impacting low-income
consumers as is whether or not it would
actually ever work when enacted by
governments but in the itf's opinion
along with suspending tax breaks for
shipping and Aviation carbon pricing is
an effective tool to decarbonize
transports especially stubbornly
difficult to decarbonize long distance
transport
in the absence of better options this
may prove decisive and where were the
money generated by this carbon pricing
go well it could go to governments to
pay for steps 1 to 13 in decarbonizing
transport it's almost like the ITF
thought of this clearly this is a
complex problem as the distance traveled
increases it gets harder and harder to
reduce emissions but strategies exist at
every distance scale and for passengers
and for Freight together we think
they're enough the international
transport Forum modeled steps 1 to 14 in
a high ambition policy scenario and
estimated that even considering growing
population demand and Associated social
changes transport emissions can be cut
to around one quarter of current Levels
by the year 2050. more emissions Cuts
than even the 1.5 degrees Target of the
ipcc requires
we have the ideas and much of the
technology now governments must be bold
plan into the future invest in the tech
decide on a course of action and provide
the solutions it doesn't need to happen
all at once even the highly ambitious
modeling assumed that policy would
change slowly over decades but it does
need to happen
step 15 in decarbonizing transport is
starting
now
something else you can start now is
using your phone to improve your
understanding of the world around you
learning about statistics or physics or
computer science you can do so with
brilliant who have kindly sponsored this
video brilliant.org is an educational
app and website designed to help
students and young professionals reach
their goals in maths science and
computer science whether you're a stem
student looking for a fun way to
supplement their learning in the
classroom or simply someone who wants to
keep their mind active and learning new
things brilliant has courses and guided
learning paths for you there are
thousands of lessons ranging from
foundational to graduate level are
interactive beautifully Illustrated and
cover topics ranging from geometry to
Vector calculus gears to relativity if
you found this video interesting you'll
enjoy their series of lessons on
infrastructure including the physics of
airplanes and modeling traffic jams as
fluid flows this isn't an app that makes
you memorize answers through bite size
lessons it actually helps you understand
the topics and improves your intuition
and problem solving techniques if I was
in school right now I would absolutely
be using brilliant to support my
learning in maths classes to get started
today head to brilliant.org Simon Clark
Linked In the description and get a
30-day free trial the first 200 of you
to do so will also get 20 off a premium
annual subscription that's brilliant.org
Simon Clark to supercharge the way you
look at the world with thanks to
brilliant for sponsoring this video and
for continuing to be well brilliant
as already mentioned this video is
overwhelmingly based on the
international transport forum's 2023
Report with some information from the
2022 report and from drawdown edited by
Paul Hawkin links to all those are in
the description I'd recommend you give
them a read for detailed sets of
proposals to enact the changes described
in this video
this video also wouldn't have been
possible without the support of two
groups of people first of all Andy Sam
and ferox for their assistance in
capturing game footage frankly I think
it was any excuse to play open TTD and
secondly my patrons these lovely people
are my executive producers and have a
say in one video topic a month if you
would like to support my work get
exclusive behind the scenes Vlogs and
have a say in what videos I make
consider supporting me on my patreon
that just leads me to say thank you very
much for watching if you'd like to watch
something else please check out the
videos on the screen right now and I'll
see you in the next one